Hello.
Welcome.
I'm just gonna wait
a minute
so that I can confirm
I can see myself
down here.
Yep.
Hello.
Stupid voice me. Alright.
So yesterday wasn't very successful.
If you didn't watch that video, then we
spent two hours yesterday.
The first thirty minutes were fine.
We got alerting configured
on pods
that were
struggling to start.
Then we moved on to trying to provide
a kind of logging section of our dashboard.
And we ran into a few problems.
Now after much,
much debugging,
it turns out that there was a problem
in the InfluxDB
with FluentD plugin.
The problem was
even though it was staring me right in
the face and I I didn't see it
was just
that
the
there is a nested JSON.
Well, I thought it was a string
that was heading the conditional statement
and the Ruby plugin.
Okay. We can even just take a look
at that code again.
Even though we looked at that a fair
amount yesterday.
It was down here
where it says, you know, oops, go back.
No.
Where are you?
Well, wonder if he fixed this fixed this
in two.
I'm sure there was a string that is
skipped. Anyway, this is out here that was
part of the add field function anyway. So
the the add field function has a check
on it. At least for being a string
and that
it quotes the key and the value appropriately.
However, the string handling is also just
it has an else field on it that
just says okay, just just use key value
pairs. We don't really know what we're dealing
with here.
So
what the maintainer now has handled is we
actually, if we notice that it is an
object or hash in Ruby chat,
look over the the those pairs and actually
process them each as fields.
And he was very kind to do a
pre release for me
that I have updated
in my Docker file.
So we're now running the one four o
pre release of the fluid deep plugin. I
have triggered a rebuild
and that's where we are.
So hopefully my cluster is in the same
state I left in and
it is
our fluent plugin has been running for twenty
two hours. We wanna cause this pod to
re star.
But let's just take a look at what
we were getting. So
big blob of text
and valid billion here.
Just struggling to process this.
So I'm hoping
very quickly,
I'm gonna delete this pod. The new image
is already on many QPM.
It's gonna deploy it with an update
and magically,
we're gonna see logs.
Is that too much to ask? I don't
think so.
Okay. So tell to tell, that's all of
our container logging files.
I'm not sure if we'll see any sort
of output to indicate that the metrics have
been written, but I am gonna give this
around thirty seconds
because it is batch and buffered.
So we won't see it right and if
an immediately
and we'll see what happens.
Now if we pull up our dashboard again,
will need my port forward.
Get lab.
Fire.
Port art.
Let's pull this back up.
Hopefully, I remember the username and password.
Oh, no. Wait.
This is configured by the cluster.
You go away for one day
and you forget how your computer
gets secrets
admin password.
We do need to basically code this. I'm
sure everyone is so fed up of watching
me do this. I should just save it
somewhere, shouldn't I?
Okay. So password.
So we go to our fire dashboard.
We can see our broken pods.
Nice.
Good.
We want logs.
We definitely want logs.
So I'm gonna come in here, our logs
Oh, nice. Our logs are being run into
the telegraph bucket because
stupid thing that's how decided to configure it.
We have a measurement
for each
of our containers.
So let's
let's try and understand this data a little
bit more. I don't wanna filter on measurement.
I'm actually gonna pull them all out
and see if there's something else I can
filter on.
We only need the last five minutes.
View the raw data.
Nice.
And
alright. So we do have container name here.
What else do I have?
I got generation information.
I got the pod ID.
We've got the
log itself.
No. I think that was just confusing me
there. I think this is just the fluent
d log lines from when it prints out
its own config at the start.
And so let's just skip over that
and
we have the host. So
this is rather unusual right
now.
What we need to do is pivot this
data.
So
by default,
when you query measurements with flux,
you get back data in a column or
fashion
which means that we get a table stream
for each series key
and if we want to view that on
a row based fashion, we need to decide
how we group those columns together to form
a row and then use the pivot function.
And I think that is step one because
right now,
this is gobbledygook.
I don't understand what this is.
So how do we group this?
I think we can go on pod
name.
So
let's try a
group
columns.
Sometimes
you get all complete on actual data values
like here.
Don't know why it doesn't work for columns.
So
let's try to to to
pod container
name.
Let's just try container name.
Let's just comment out and actually do
that's the reason it wasn't working was probably
this, so comment back in.
Alright. We do have some grouping going on
here,
That could just be
Kubernetes.
Oh, no. Wait. Well, it's
let's work this out. We wanna grip on
fluent d tag.
Okay. So fluent.
So when we configure fluent d, we had
a we had a fluent d tag and
it adds a tag with the file name
for the
it's just a container or the pod. I
think it's a container.
So if I group by that
and then let's just go straight onto a
numb on
pivot.
We probably don't need to grip because we
can specify the Rawkode is
fluent D.
We wanna
all of our columns will be anything that
has a field. The value is always value.
Yay.
So now we have
that's our broken and a container
and that's each of the broken ones because
we have two pods.
We got the namespace. We got the labels.
We got the host.
Docker container ID.
We got pod ID. Now I think pod
ID is a slightly nicer
thing to group
potentially.
I don't know. You probably want to view
your logs
from each container. Would you want the logs
from each container in a pod group together?
Potentially.
I think there's definitely a use case for
that but I don't
think I understand it well enough just yet.
Let's see what it looks like.
Alright.
Cancel that.
The reason that is is because it's field
and not tag.
So when it's a field, I would have
to
yeah. That wouldn't work.
We can only really
we can only pivot based on a tag
key. So okay. We're gonna force here to
use this one we have in fluent.
If we did want to group all of
the containers
to view the logs on a pod level,
I would have to change the fluent deconfig
I believe.
Just to expose a few extra things
as a tag. I think the pod ID
would definitely be one of those I'd want.
And there's a few other things in here
that I don't think are tags
such as the, you know, the node name
and things that we may want to slice
and dice by.
But for now,
we're just gonna go with
this.
So if I view this as a table
well, I'm on raw data.
What do we have?
Not what I was expecting.
So now I look at the raw data
again.
Where's my log lane?
Log.
I just cannot
Okay.
So I think
the problem is
my grip key.
Because of the pivot.
Okay. Let's try
and get our key correct first.
And I think we're gonna use Linde.
What we should see here
is many many entries
table which is each of the log lines.
And I can kinda
encourage only seeing log lines for now but
we will take this out.
And what we wanna see is where a
field
equals
log, I think it was.
Yep. So now we've the log lines
for this this is just one container
because the group key is on fluent d,
which is a container tag
and I should have multiple tables, yep, for
each container.
So that is
better.
This
I mean, it feels like
I shouldn't have any tables with one line.
Do I have a container that's only logged
one line?
I'm not sure.
Let's keep moving forward.
So if I then pivot now,
we're back to one log line. Okay. So
that's not right.
What am I not doing correctly here?
Okay. So the pivot,
working on fluent d.
I think I need to
add the time.
So if we throw in this,
I don't think these are needed right now.
Yeah. That's better.
Because obviously the timestamp is different.
We have a different role.
So we have
something. Yeah. This is much better.
And I don't think I need the grip
but let's confirm here.
Okay. Perfect.
So
the group key already has
the measurement name there.
We're good.
I think that cleans up our series key.
We do that. I'll remove measurement
per chance.
Yep. So we just got the d as
it's just a pod indicator.
We can do logs for each pod. Also,
we're getting a little bit
too
much information
at the moment. So
let's try and work out what we actually
want
and we can use keep to do that.
I think it's just columns but
we'll just do this.
Delete mine.
But it's columns.
Alright. So
we don't
need to keep this. This is here.
Start and stop.
No. I think I just want
time.
Do I need to know the container ID?
Might be handy.
Do I want to know the container name?
I believe so.
So we'll keep that.
Do I need to know the host? I
believe that's viable.
Do I need labels?
No.
At least not not right now. I don't
need to know the name Swiss ID. No.
But the name Swiss name, I will keep
a hold of that.
Have port ID.
Maybe I would rather the port ID than
the container ID.
Yeah.
Let's do that. So we'll do Kubernetes,
pod ID,
with the container name,
the host, the namespace.
We definitely need to log
and I may wish to filter on the
stream.
Looks like maybe every finish is standard out,
so maybe not. Okay.
We'll come back to that.
So if I had to go on this,
So I don't think maybe
like me not keeping that in.
We
can hide that on the table level though.
So
not too big a deal. So we can
just go over here.
We just see it on show.
Let's sort by the time.
I'm still disappointed I can't pick the order,
but that where it's ascending or descending.
But that's a feature request that's been made
and
we have the ability to view the logs.
So let's save this to fire.
Fire.
And we'll call this
container
logs.
I'm gonna come back over here
and let's put it in a rather unhelpful
position, but it's okay. We'll move it.
Let's stick that here.
And I just got a bit bigger.
Oh, that's annoying.
Okay. Getting there.
I
think there needs to be like a little
maybe it's just my browser up. Yeah. There
we go.
Okay. So
now we can see that we have
our fluent d logs.
I should probably change the
order of this.
So what do I want?
I'll start and stop aren't kept anyway. Measurement
isn't kept. Container ID wasn't kept. Container name.
Put the host above that,
labels aren't kept,
that wasn't kept.
Namespace name. So yeah, we'll have host, namespace
name, container name,
pod ID,
pod name.
Don't think I'm doing anything with that. And
then we want to log
Field value
to one stream and let's get the time
at the start. I want this to feel
like actual
I'm actually doing log data.
So
go.
Okay. I like it.
The log actually has a timestamp and stuff
in it too. That's
particularly annoying.
I'm sure the plug in
can clean that up.
But it's not important for now.
Yeah. Really, I I wanna see
much more of this.
What if we just remove some context then?
Go away.
Just give me the time and the log.
Keep the log.
Woah. Don't do that.
Don't
I haven't even wait.
That doesn't help me.
My computer's
going a little bit slow.
I can't resize that.
I mean obviously the log is useless to
me without the time, but the time is
well it's only on some.
Yeah. Okay. There's a little bit of work
to be done here for sure.
The API server just has one.
So the broken in it,
kinda what I'm looking for.
Yep.
That's good.
Fluent d. I mean, I'm not particularly fussed
about edge logs anyway.
These are the ones that I care about.
So
I kinda have what I need for now.
I think it can be better. It could
and can be better.
So
I'll need to get
my typescript hands dirty
and try and provide the features we need
to make log in a bit better. So
what I what I will say is
the table viewer
isn't for viewing and consuming log data. Right?
This is what I have to do right
now.
The team is working on supporting
the
an actual log viewer. Similar to what we
had in chronograph one.
Log
viewer.
It just hasn't really been repurposed for two
point x yet.
So if you're not familiar with what we
had in one point x,
I don't think I can make that
bigger.
You know, I had a nice log viewer.
I had, you know, tools that handled syslog
format by pulling in the severity and, you
know, allowed you to kind of the logs
would move as you moved across
the x y plots, the graphs.
So
this is just what I have to do
right now and not something that I'm telling
you would be part of your final solution.
Obviously two point X is still in beta,
lots of improvements to come and this definitely
needs a little bit of loving.
But for the time being, you know, as
we're just really trying to put together a
dashboard.
So let's talk about the Kubernetes monitoring aspect
first.
Right.
So
there are three components
needed
for production grade monitoring of Kubernetes.
Kubernetes runs on hardware
even if it's virtualized.
So what doesn't go away because you're using
Kubernetes is understanding how to monitor the bare
metal or the VMs.
And we have dashboards for that.
You know, Linux system dashboard gives us a
way to look
at, you know, our CPU usage. We've got
load, processes, swap,
desks, network.
None of that changes. You know, Brendan Greg's
use framework is still the de facto standard
here.
We're just understanding the host. And if you
keep your host healthy and happy,
then you're then
really just focusing on the other two components
of the Kubernetes monitoring experience.
The third component, I'll skip the second for
now
Is the application and service layer.
And
again,
we're
not reinventing the wheel there either.
So we're still using either four golden signals
if you've read the Google SRE book, the
red method, if you're familiar with the work
of
Tom Welke.
You know, understanding your application through requests, errors,
duration, saturation.
That is still really important there.
So when we actually talk about Kubernetes monitoring,
we're talking about this little bit in the
middle,
which is just understanding
that
controller loop, the reconciliation loop that happens within
the cluster.
So really all we want from this Kubernetes
fire dashboard
is,
I mean, on very basic level for now
is to understand, do we have pods aren't
running that we want to be running? Now,
yes, there's other stuff I'm gonna add in
here.
I wanna understand the
PVCs.
I wanna know what PVCs are unbound, why
they're unbound. I wanna know if those PVCs
are approaching capacity.
I wanna try and do that proactively as
possible. So we're trying to linear protections to
to protect
those desks filling up.
We wanna predict that in office hours whatever
those mean for your team
versus
getting woken up at 3AM.
That's
the goal. We're not gonna do PVCs today
but there will be a video on that
I guess within the next week as we
kinda mature this dashboard.
But for our pods solution right now, we
do have the ability to alert and detect
when we have a reconciliation
problem. Something cannot be started or scheduled.
And we have the reasons. We made the
changes to the telegraph plugin for that yesterday.
We know we have pod initializing problem here.
We have the container pod logs.
We know that it can't initialize because it's
looking for a service that doesn't exist.
So on this one dashboard,
we have identified a problem.
We know which pods we need to look
at. We know what the status of that
pod is.
We can filter the container logs on that
pod
and we have the error message right in
front of us with not a lot of
vertical scroll.
So to fix this,
my broken deployment, I kept in a different
folder because we were using a really good
example library from Ian.
GitHub
Ian, Kubernetes examples.
We deployed the broken in it.
We can pop that open.
And we know
I'm sorry. This is very contrived example.
We know that service
doesn't exist.
We know that it's in the in the
container.
So this is an easy fix.
I'm not going to replace this. I mean,
if we wanted to fix this, I could
fix the host name.
Google.com.
Maybe that's what I meant.
Or maybe not, but.
And we can apply.
So we run a watcher.
And if we come back to our dashboard
here.
We have our five second refresh on.
Pod waiting pods have gone up. That's okay.
I
would expect this to drop as those
metrics come in.
One says with a slight
bit of hope in his voice.
So I think that's just because we're waiting
on those old ones terminating there.
So this was the two new ones we
spun up, which became healthy, dropped back down,
and then we're waiting for the two old
ones to be cleaned up.
The old replica set to be removed.
Terminating. Terminating.
I'm
happy.
Okay.
So
as a dashboard for debugging,
I think we're making good progress.
We still wanna clean up these numbers.
I don't want a total over the last
five minutes.
I really just want what is waiting now.
But I do have a graph that shows
me that. So it's not my most pressing
concern. Now I only have an hour to
stream today which means I have twenty nine
minutes left before I have a meeting.
So what I want to do next is
take a look at vector.
So what we've deployed here
and again,
have you have you seen yesterday's video, you
know, I'm not happy with what we had
to put together to deploy this.
We had to build our own flow of
the image. We had to configure all of
the Kubernetes stuff and the InfluxDB stuff and
the stuff.
It was quite a lot of effort.
And I want to make that easier.
Yep.
I wanna make that a lot a lot
easier.
So I think my stream
won't be tomorrow.
Tomorrow
our company has given us time off for
Juneteenth.
A lot of us in the company have
decided to use the day to read up
on
on history and educate ourselves more in the
current situation around the world.
So I won't be streaming.
So maybe on Monday,
we will clean up the fluid deployment so
that I can package up in a really
nice fashion for you all to consume.
So what I want to do next,
and I'm just gonna we don't need any
of this running now.
Clear screen, close tab.
What I wanna do is see
I can't put forward, which is why this
has disappeared.
What I want to have a go at
now is can I deploy vector? I have
never used vector before. I think it looks
really cool.
I like, if I believe correctly, it's written
in Rust.
Rust is the new shiny language that I'm
trying to get familiar with and good at.
I like their website. It shouldn't be a
decision factor, but it kinda is.
I like this graph that shows it is
super
good with the disk IO.
I find it weird that they hide the
fact, not hide I guess because as on
the page but it's just not the default,
know. Sell your best self first to guess.
From memory consumption point of view is really
good. Little right behind file beat. And from
a CPU, seems to be kinda middle of
the road. Flint D and Flint B actually
surprised me better. I wouldn't have thought that.
Of course, this is a particular use case.
You know, if we
pop along, it does change.
Fluent bit is surprisingly fast. It is written
in C.
And the reason I'm not going to try
and get a fluent bit to work in
the cluster
is
there's not a
plugin
that would allow me to write to InfluxDB
two.
There's no c client library, which means I
would have to be straight up using a
c http library
too much move too many moving parts. I
don't wanna do that. So
for the next twenty six minutes now, we
are gonna do our best and our damnedest
to deploy vector.
First things first.
Do we have a docker image?
Maybe I should search
timber
vector.
So if I do u
I mean, that's a long shot, isn't it?
I got interested when I seen the fluent
d there, but it just I think it's
just just
a
bit random.
Timber IO.
Yeah.
There you go. Second time lucky.
So we do have an image.
So let's copy this.
Now, I did
I did what?
Timber
vector
dev
deployment. I don't think there's gonna be a
health chart, do you? I don't.
I'll check.
I think I did check.
Or was I looking for something else? Who
knows?
Who knows?
Alright.
So really
simple deployment.
What do we need to do?
So we can pass a custom configuration fail
because
the default
doesn't do anything
nice.
I'm okay with that.
I'm
gonna deploy the nation in Alpine one though.
And
let's take a look at this
config doc then.
Where do I need to put this?
Fetra vector default toml.
Oh, so that is their default. Gotcha. Okay.
So let's add a config map.
V one
config.
Oh, now you're offering me a config then.
Oh,
vector dot pommel.
Oh, is that just
there we go.
Stuff. Okay. Alright. We've got a conflict now.
So I already have an examples folder that
makes me happy.
Less I have to do,
the happier I am.
I was hoping there would be Kubernetes
example.
So let's click on
let's click on sources.
We wanted to log, so I'll look at
it as a metric collector layer.
Docker.
So that would require me to mount in
the docker socket
from
and the deployment.
We probably
want to run that as a daemon set,
not deployment, meant under docker socket.
But wouldn't be ubiquitous. A lot of people
don't use
Docker run time by default anymore.
So let's not do that.
Would
have been nice if there was a
Kubernetes option,
but I guess they just want us to
use the fail from that.
So we could just point it at the
directory.
Let's try that.
So drop this.
Don't need to use list comments.
Type fail.
I'm gonna call this Kubernetes.
File collector,
optional, no default,
ignore older.
Let's just collect everything.
Where did those live? File, log
containers.
Hopefully,
that persistent offset.
Let's just remove that. Let's confirm what those
logs are first. So many cube
SSH.
Yep.
Bar, let,
containers.
Nope.
Bar log
containers.
Yep. Start out log.
Let's just tail.
Acube controller manager.
And
it's JSON structured.
Okay.
So
next.
What is it?
Lots of options.
Okay. Hard passer now.
Definitely interesting.
Okay. Let's keep moving. So now that we
have
assuming that can I just out put
syncs,
log syncs?
I might just do console for now. I
just wanna
get this working.
Make sure it
so I can get our feedback loop going.
I wanna get this running as quickly as
possible consuming, I'll put into our console. I'll
just tell the logs and vector
and I'll run it as a deployment on
one node for now and we'll see what's
happening because I think I'm gonna have to
play with these transformation functions
to do something with the JSON,
I'm assuming.
So sync console
inputs.
Kubernetes.
I don't know if it wants source dot
Let's assume maybe.
Right. Just standard out.
This is required.
So let's just leave it as is.
And then we wanna mount this into our
deployment.
So
volumes,
name,
config,
config map,
name,
enter
config.
Yeah. No need to be.
Volume,
etcetera,
vector,
config,
toml.
Maybe
Vector dot TOML.
I don't think that's right.
Name,
config
one.
Cool. Let's
I think let's just go for it.
For a config map,
deploy the deployment.
See what happens.
So right now it's gonna be pulling down
the image.
And I have seventeen minutes before my meeting.
Drats.
What I get wrong?
I mean, should we use my dashboard?
I mean, I could describe it, but you
know, we're building this for a reason and
if I don't find it useful, other people
won't find it useful.
Broken part.
We have a
run container error.
Where are my logs?
There won't be any logs. So there we
go.
I know there's a run container error,
but I'm not getting the message.
Do I have did I add that field
to telegraph?
So let's we're gonna have to keep
and see.
So I've got
we wanna move remove that field.
And terminated reason.
Restart state
code, state reason we have
alright. I think we can make another change
to telegraph layer
because
we're obviously missing some context that I want.
That context should be here when I describe
the pod.
Yes.
I want this.
Although these are the cubelet logs. So
I probably do have them.
No.
Alright.
There's something we need to work on. Okay.
But my mount is wrong. Let's fix that
first.
So the problem is my config map, although
only has one key
and we should specify the sub path.
I only wanna mount vector dot toml.
That should
hopefully
fix it.
Container creating.
And we still got an adder.
Okay.
So something wrong with our config, is that
in my dashboard?
Just a hard refresh.
Contain an impact. Alright. Good.
Oh, wait. That's
that's the Y.
I'll crash look back off.
Why is fluent d
not giving me all of my log data?
It didn't give me the cubelet.
And it's not giving me vector.
I wonder if there's just a delay
from
bucket. Let's
telegraph
range.
I'm just gonna do this very quickly so
that we can make progress again.
Give me everything. Give me the raw data.
So let's filter on containers,
Kubernetes name.
Filter
function takes a role.
Our dot
build
Kubernetes
container
name.
Weird syntax of me.
Okay. So container name is Flint, Flint, Flint,
Flint, Flint, Flint,
etcd
vector.
Was I just too impatient?
I
wonder if we can tweak the buffer on
that.
Okay. So we can see here that we've
got unknown variant, codec,
expected text or JSON.
I'm sure I copied this from their docs.
And then variant codec
expected text or JSON for key syncs on
console.
It is JSON?
Doesn't give me a lane number,
but it does not have a console output.
So definitely getting my config
fail.
Let's have a look
here.
I'm sorry. Syncs.
Console.
And this is where I copied it from.
And
I I
mean, that looks okay.
Alright. When in doubt
my favorite
hack approach to everything ever.
I'm sorry for anyone that sees me doing
this.
But I want inside of this container.
Ash.
Back to our cat,
my config.
Me using the wrong
thing here.
Yeah. The dash will strip the trailing. Right.
Okay.
Remove the sleep.
Remove
the sleep.
I'm gonna delete it. Oh, that tells me
I might need it.
Run pods.
Two seconds.
Crash load.
I use my dashboard.
Although then I need to wait for the
buffer.
Maybe I should
twelve seventeen twelve. Yeah. It's a couple
of minutes
behind. I'm not gonna wait a couple of
minutes because that will happen.
So
vector,
the new one is five.
Alright, sleep. You're back in the game.
Oh,
Oh, wait. That that would be my sleep.
Right?
Am I jogging too many pods?
And that's just the same one.
I haven't deployed the config map.
Oh, come on YouTube. You should have told
me.
Call it that out.
Let's just do
should've just done a briefing anyway.
Okay.
Damn you, error.
Five.
Alright. Tagging back in the sleep.
We are going to get this working in
the next five minutes. I assure you. I
am going to just
delete,
delete, delete.
Alright. That's the one we want. 74GAsh.
I'm gonna take a look at the fail.
Looks better.
Better.
I still don't have that new line. Is
that the problem?
Oh, it's a.
You know what? Let's
x.
And sometimes I guess you can copy weird
quotes. That's been a thing before.
Let's reapply both.
Get pods.
Delete
part. I mean, that config map where we
load, but let's just
get parts.
No matter what software I use,
just
I run into bugs.
Take a screenshot.
And
save.
Disappointing.
I really wanted
vector running,
but unfortunately,
time is against me today
and
bugs.
I
mean, I could just attach it in FluxDB
output, but I'd need to do it in
like three and a half minutes. No. Okay.
We're stopping for today.
Okay.
We did get fluent D working.
We do have a dashboard that allows me
to do
decent
retroactive debugging for problems
In combination with the alerting, we will,
you know, make this all a lot nicer
over the next week,
but
we're making progress.
I will speak to the team. We'll work
out
what
the timelines are for a nice log viewer,
which would be very exciting for me. I
may see if there's any short term improvements
I can make to the table viewer for
logs.
I think even just having the ascending, the
descending option
on
just on the
table customizer would be really good just to
get those logs. You want the most recent
ones first.
As far as the D goes, plugins working
well. I like we have loads of fields
available that we consume but I really wanna
be able to control
the size of that buffer and that batch.
I don't want to wait three minutes
when there are logs.
I think thirty seconds, maybe one minute I'll
deal with, but if longer, maybe too much.
Anyway,
I will dig into this vector bug. I
will see if there's already an issue failed.
And if not, I will try to fix
it myself.
I won't be back tomorrow. I will be
back on Monday. Have a great weekend, and
thank you very much for tuning in. Have
a good day.